Facebook is broadening its definition of
Vande hate speech and taking action
against white nationalism and white
separatism the social media giant said
yesterday that those concepts are linked
to organized hate groups and quote have
no place on our services Facebook had
previously banned post endorsing white
supremacy Jeff Pegues shows us how
Facebook made the change
after months of pressure from civil
rights groups less than two weeks after
a white supremacist live-streamed his
deadly attack at a New Zealand mosque
Facebook hopes its new policy will help
prevent the promotion of hateful content
arguably these category should always
have fallen within the community
guidelines of hate speech but near the
release it's positive that clarification
has now been made starting next week
Facebook and Instagram will ban praise
support and representation of white
nationalism and separatism saying it's
clear that these concepts are deeply
linked to organized hate groups civil
rights attorney Kristen Clark there was
a huge gaping hole that allowed violent
white supremacists and neo-nazis and
racists to exploit the Facebook platform
self avowed white nationalists used
Facebook to organize the unite the right
rally in Charlottesville where James
fields ran down and killed a counter
protester in 2017 he pled guilty to
committing a hate crime Wednesday
facebook says it has been cracking down
on hate speech last year it says it took
action on nearly eight million pieces of
content that violated its rules the
volume need not stop them from doing
their job and doing their part to make
sure that they're standing up to hate on
Wednesday Facebook acknowledged that it
needs to get better and faster at
finding and removing hate from its
platforms it says the artificial
intelligence it uses to find material
from terrorist groups will now be used
for a broad range of hate groups YouTube
and Twitter say both their user
agreements also prohibit violent and
hateful content it is
so critical that we get Facebook and
other companies across the tech sector
to do their part we must hold them
accountable for CBS this morning Jeff
Pegues Washington I think that's a very
good sign you think we can do to tone it
down
thank you Facebook